j'ai maintenant vous montrer une
couverture d'un magazine vous le savez
la vérité c'est qu'ils lohan a
métamorphosé en couverture du magazine
elle est regardée loana c'est
franchement non on est content pour elle
oui la roumanie couverture du tout
dernier magazine elle elle évoque en
exclusivité sa renaissance après sa
descente aux enfers et sur la couverture
du magazine on peut voir que loana elle
et elle est magnifique elle est allée à
26 elle est très bien habillé regardez
donc le chef c'est pas mal quand même
al wahda mardié bien ouais bah
magnifique merci oui alors ses 17 ans
après sa victoire du loft tout cas la
gagne évidemment un
elle a fait son souci c'était de maigrir
bon il ya eu tous ses démons la drogue
et tout le reste elle en parle très
librement dedans mais surtout elle a
fait une gastrectomie c'est à dire
qu'elle s'est enlevé une partie de
l'estomac et donc ça et efficace du coup
parce qu'elle a beaucoup perdu
elle est vraiment adorable chez très
content qu'ils aient une renaissance et
en plus cela son bouquin qui sort le
tout dernier
alors elle a dévoilé on exclut des
extraits suisse de son livre voilà dans
l
si dur et la demie si tendre et la vie
on dirait un truc pour un fromage au
médiator on dirait le sang les coutures
et la nuit mais bon nous rendrait la vie
yoann à ce mondial j'ai toujours été là
pour elle et je la kiffe elle le sait et
je laime vraiment énormément et j'adore
cette fille et la laisser vos tâches
confiées c'est notamment confié au sujet
de la drogue
la cocaïne est une drogue terrifiante
parce que des gens consomment je me sens
la reine du monde avec la délicieuse
impression de n'avoir jamais été aussi
bien dans ma vie dans mon corps je plane
je suis au strict donc c'est fou cd
dégraisser rejoindre ses deux grosses
révélations le pire c'est que je me pose
aucune question sur la profusion de 7
mars marchandises dont la source n'a
jamais l'air de s'épuiser
comme par magie des sachets apparaissent
aux quatre coins de l'appartement
l'ennui à présent c'est que je ne suis
plus en état de réfléchir à de tels
détails
une seule chose m'apporte meadows c'est
fou alors le livre soit n'at on va en
parler la semaine prochaine mais a fait
des mets confession incroyable voilà
donc c'était le top five l'eau